تعزيز وتطوير الجيش
أمن موثوق للبلد
كان ولا يزال لدينا غير مشروط
الأولوية نظرا للتحديات الجديدة و
بالتأكيد
تجربة لا تقدر بثمن في عقد خاص
سنواصل العملية العسكرية بشكل شامل
تحسين الجيش
أهم مهمة هنا هي تطوير الطاقة النووية
الثالوث الذي هو المفتاح
ضمان الأمن العسكري لروسيا و
الاستقرار العالمي في المستقبل القريب
سيأتي وقت الخدمة القتالية
أول قاذفات للمجمع
سارمات بصاروخ ثقيل جديد
بما يتفق بدقة مع الخطط
يتم تجديدها مع ترسانة الطيران و
المكونات البحرية للاستراتيجية
سوف تستمر القوات النووية
تحسين تصنيع النظام
حرب مضادة للبطارية وكذلك
نشر القوات غير المأهولة
الطائرات والروبوتية
مجمعات الصدمات التي هي جيدة
أظهروا أنفسهم في ظروف القتال
قوة إنتاجهم الضخم